All right. Hello everyone. How are you
guys doing? Hope you guys are having a
wonderful day. And I I mean people just
so disrespectful, man. Just keep walking
on through me. But it is what it is. So,
uh today we are here with another
moneymaking guide. So, as you guys know,
I like to be the first in breaking new
and great money-making method. So, uh
this is a freetoplay and paytoplay
method. So, uh any of you guys, whatever
you're doing right now, I'd pretty much
stop and uh take a look at this video.
So, we're going to go ahead and get with
it. So, right now, basically all you're
going to need if you are pay to play, go
ahead and get yourself an amulet of
glory. As you guys can see right here, I
also have some GP in my inventory that
is not necessary, and I will be banking
that here in a second. So, as far as
requirements go for this one, I mean,
you would think for a money-making
method as good as this one that there
would be way more requirements than
there are. But, surprisingly enough, you
just have to be smart enough to make
your way over to Edgeville. So, once you
get your way over to Edgeville, that's
about it. And realistically, I don't
know if this will ever be nerfed, but uh
I'd imagine after the release of this
video, it definitely could be. So, we're
going to go ahead and uh get on with it.
So, you're going to want to charge your
amulet of glory or just, you know, sit
here and uh run to the edge yourself,
but personally, just to be more
efficient, I'm going to go ahead and buy
myself an amulet of glory. I'm also
doing this on my noob account to show
how little requirements you need. So, if
that uh isn't impressive, I don't know
what is. All right. So, once you're
ready and you have a teleportation
method, you want to make some money, go
ahead and grab the uh glory, go to
Edgeville, and I mean, this is just my
preferred way. You can get here however
you want, but if you want to get the
best GP per hour, I definitely recommend
doing this. So, from here, you're going
to want to run down here. This is what
you call a bank. Go ahead and throw
ahead and put everything in here. You
can wear some armor if you want, just in
case, you know, if you're in a PvP
world, if you end up hopping around,
that's uh perfectly fine. I'd recommend
red dehide as it just looks the best.
So, that's personally all I have. And
with 60 range, I think it's the most
efficient. So, I'm going to go ahead and
get that. And uh you know, you're going
to want to be able to fend off whatever
you know, rats or other monsters you may
see. So, I'll grab a DK skim as well.
But uh other than that, you're just
going to want to uh run south a little
bit out of the bank. And then uh once
you run south, you will uh run directly
east. And as you guys can see on OS
Buddy, it shows right here, leather
gloves. So, what you're going to want to
do is these things spawn in every world.
I know, insane, right? But what you're
going to want to do is just pick up the
glove. And once you do that, you already
have one leather gloves in your
inventory. So the respawn rate on these
aren't the best, which is maybe why this
isn't the best money-making method in
the game. But if you want to increase
it, I recommend just hopping world to
world. Uh if you're free to play, you
won't have as many worlds to hop to. So
uh
rip. So me personally, I'm going to go
ahead and test this out for about an
hour and uh we'll see how much money we
can make. I'm thinking somewhere in
between like 3 to 4k, but uh maybe you
throw an auto clicker on this. I mean,
I'm not recommending you bot, but if you
really want to make the best money in
the game while you're sleeping, I don't
know. It may be worth it to you. All
right, you may be asking yourself, what
do you think is the best method of going
about banking? Personally, I don't see
going to Castle Wars being the best
method. What I would do is I'd probably
just run to the north. As you guys can
see, there is a bank to the north. And
go ahead and just use your bank booth.
From there, just press deposit
inventory, and you should be good to go.
So, if you can't find your way back
because the uh leather gloves have
despawned, go ahead and hop another
world and you'll probably be able to
find it. So, I'm going to go ahead and
start up on this little journey and
we'll see how much money we can make.
All right, so here we go. Ending off the
hour. So, let's go ahead. We'll end up
switching one more world and uh then
we'll price check and see what we got.
So, uh here we go. Going to go to the
bank. Time to reveal what I have got.
So, give me a second. All right, there
we go. So, last inventory of gloves.
Let's look up and see how much we have.
So, there we go. 649 leather gloves. Not
too shabby if you ask me. I'd say uh I'd
say this is, you know, relatively close
to Zora, but let's go ahead and uh see
how much money this is going to end up
being for us. So, there we go. 2,000
coins. I'm a little disappointed. I
thought it'd be more closer to three or
four, but I guess as soon as I started
doing it, I realized that uh you know,
it's not as quick considering the world
hops take a while. But uh yeah, it is
what it is. So, we we did pretty good, I
would say. You know, I mean, think about
it. It's 648 in-game items, so I mean,
you know, if they go up a little bit,
this could be viable. Who knows? All
right. So, if you guys enjoyed the
video, make sure to leave that like
button. If you guys have anything you
want to tell me, leave it a comment down
below. If you guys want to see my videos
as soon as I go live, obviously, make
sure to subscribe and check out the
Twitter in the uh description down
below. You can also, if you want to talk
to me, hit me up in the game. You can
you can private chat me. You can join
07helpers. I don't have it written right
here, but here it is. Everything is
going to the there. join that join that
chat. But nonetheless, I hope you guys
have a wonderful day and
[Music]
Are you